picchiate sale l'orgasmo questa musica
quella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj oggi siamo su
conan super detective non è quel siamo
su conan che è un videogioco che mette
uscito da pochi si alzi da in accesso
anticipato quindi la roma ancora più
[ __ ] credo sia una specie di the forest
brom forse anche un po più figo mica
facciamo questo perché se veramente c'è
un servo italiano però non serve agli
italiani di conan e xvi exile ex il es
io non so l'inglese ha finito gesù
cristo quindi sono gesu in partenza ma
che figata
sei contento di essere crocifisso no
puoi andare a mangiare un bel gelato
se come razza mettiamo no vabbè ma non
possono esservi razzisti ma cos'è una la
dark polo gang questo è stato il soprano
blunt lei io capisco comunque che gli
spazi pubblicitari siano sempre più
difficili da affittare però porca [ __ ]
pro sullo stomaco todo di mettere
ragazzi giochiamo la voce che sia un pò
simile alla mia perché sono ecco sei tu
il mio salvatore
6 tulanti giuda grazie amico avrai tutti
i video in anteprima prima che escono
sul canale solo perché sei mio amico
grazie dove cazzo andato what the fuck
ok quindi mi ha salvato salve ecco
probabilmente sarei finito così senza
l'aiuto di quei titoli prova verso
prendere le frecce non posso prendere le
frecce posso guardati sotto la gonna
c'è un bel culetto mi ha salvato sto
tizio non ho capito il perché però è
stato molto gentile e la destina manti
ragazzi dobbiamo sopravvivere
sua madre brutta ti prego non ti ho
fatto niente
scappa [ __ ] già capito con chi non
ti devi mettere contro qualcuno mi vuole
spiegare che gioco ma io posso farmi le
armi tipo scusi buon uomo non so se lei
è socievole o meno volevo chiederle e
socievole non è socievole manco per il
cazzo bene via via via via via veloce
non puoi scappare anche tu come ha fatto
il tuo amichetto di prima non scappa lui
buttati [ __ ] e fate lega beh vabbè
ce l'ho fatta ho fatta non ci credo si è
cagato è quando ti ho fatto del mio
braccio destro muscoloso ma come porca
eva e vabbè sentite [ __ ] letto e
scassato il cazzo lo picchio tutti noi
donna rambo ma cosa ha ucciso uno a
pugni in faccia ma come posso fare le
cose tipo tipo il piccone provi servono
le rocce dei bastoni va bene allora
cerchiamo delle rocce di bastoni ma è
come minecraft tipo che prendo pugni gli
alberi e casca tutto qualcosa ragazzi
dice che non è come minecraft che si
trattano le cose qua perché
effettivamente prendere a pugni un
albero non è il modo migliore per
raccogliere del legno credo per fare il
piccone serve della roccia
io come cazzo prendo della roccia senza
al piccone ma i bastoni o giusto ok
mancano 5 rocce che non ho capito come
dovrei prenderle le rocce con le prendo
scusate mi serve della roccia avete
nella roccia da qualche parte posso
dormire cio che tace
[Musica]
intravedere si esca raccogliere le rocce
con le mani in qualche strano eh eh
covelli queste sono pietre non solo
rocce come lo fai un piccone con le
pietre sticazzi piccone dai dai dai che
ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi brand ragazzi
bellissimo sta roba
porca eva stai calmo ragazzi grima e
conto di come equipaggia le cose suo zio
se questo non vale tutto il video non lo
so io
vade retro gobbo di notre dame qualunque
cosa tu sia al piano arca [ __ ] che
botta mica che vale bruttissimo pam
nuovi quello non ti spacco la famiglia
beh sempre meglio di kim kardashian ho
sete aspetta che veramente sexy 60
lascio sopra le fave ragazzi allora sono
assetato abbastanza quindi evitando il
tizio che non ho evitato direi di andare
al lago e bere un po d'acqua se riesco a
berla arkema fa vj's logic ci hai un
piccone prendilo pugni che andrebbero è
stato ucciso dalla sete stava andando a
bere porca eva ogni quanto dovere ogni
cinque secondi non ha veramente
vabbè ragazzi stavolta per la gioia di
tutti mi sono fatto kylie jenner perché
c'è una morta per terra tanto sono più
[ __ ] joanna scusate se la tipa è una
donna perché casso quando salta cia la
voce di mio zio toni nei periodi di
mascolinità più pura la prima cosa che
dobbiamo fare andare a bere perché tanto
so già che in 3 secondi
perdo tutta la sete quindi muoviamo il
culo grazie c'è qualcuno c'è qualcuno
fermi che qualcuno se devo presentarmi
che ho dei bastoni scappare sono un
amico sono amico e free and friends
freno ai fori che va voi scrive time da
ascrivere calma calma
dov'è lo pressa ficazza andata hive
perché ho aperto la mappa in questo
momento serve dell'acqua a prescindere
mi serve dell'acqua se la tipa aveva
dell'acqua ma sta roba qua l'ha
costruita qualcuno c'era già ma perché
in teoria ragazzi sto gioco si possono
costruire le cose quindi ci sta che
l'abbia costruita qualcuno ma vede non
importa dunque importante prendere
l'acqua si ghazi poi vediamo cosa ci
abbiamo intorno
santo iddio quanto tempo bevi [ __ ] non
beve non sta bevendo assisto bevendo lei
beve senza bere ok lei beve dalla vagina
beve vivere anche tu ti devo prendere a
schiaffi
porca [ __ ] che l'ha visto quello ma
comunque non laga in soggiorno ce per
carità di dio funziona tutto
perfettamente wingardium leviosa
funziona che figata centro è sempre
stato il mio sogno quello di prendere a
pugni una candela ragazzi vediamo se
dalla cima della torre disco vedere
qualcosa dunque dovrei fare
assolutamente il piccone perché prima mi
serviva un botto almeno prendo da
mangiare perché so già che se non
sopravvive un secondo dato chicca chi è
l'ingegnere idiota che ha fatto se scale
mi spieghi che problemi
ok c'è qualcosa di figo e un'altra
cappato montegrosso su così quella roba
su che bomba voglio andar lì ragazzi
fermi come andare lì assolutamente
allora vediamo cerchio su frank non
capisco che cos'è quella roba li metti
deve essere fichissimo bella del sit com
che ha fatto benissimo il nuoto invece
la camminata è fatta di merda non
dovrebbe essere il contrario al massimo
siccome io sono una persona molto molto
molto molto curiosa
c'è la possibilità di si può mettere la
nudità full volendo io posso vedere cosa
c'è sotto strano e non vi farò vedere
però ve lo faccio sapere solo perché io
sono una persona curiosa se si funziona
credo che mi divertire un sacco con
questo videogioco allora ragazzi visto
che in teoria sono messo abbastanza bene
dc di acqua e tutto quanto è il momento
di prendere da mangiare ora visto che
non credo ci sia al burger king subway
mcdonald nelle vicinanze credo che io
devo procurarmi da mangiare da solo il
che significa andare ai con i buoni
vecchi pugni perfetto vai vai vai vai al
cibo del cazzo weil e scappi una iena ma
[ __ ] o che ha posto
posso mangiare carcassa di yen a niente
aveva non aveva nulla punto vescovo è
che palle l'ho dovuta incastrare
sull'albero per ammazzarla vi rendete
conto aveva da mangiare st zia non c'è
niente con i creatori del gioco dove
credevano che si prendesse da mangiare
spiegatemi picchio tutti che poi non è
una donna che brutto coniglio oddio
oddio poverino gli spiazzi e cosa mangio
fiori 6 vegana mangia fiori non so non
capisco mi chiamava non tutto però le
hostess che arrivare in cima prima di
morire cosa che dubito che cosa brutta
ha chiuso perché mi sono messo giocare
questo gioco madonna che brutta cosa ho
visto no
non mi avvicinerò mai nella vita ante
grossa quella merda li siamo arrivati a
quella roba che avevo visto dietro le
montagne lontanissima che in teoria
ragazzi in laghi in questo momento si
sta facendo sentire più che mai però va
bè non importa spero sia un mcdonald dei
tempi antichi ragazzi magari già c'erano
anche ori fast food e immagino quindi un
entro ordino nepim il giusto perfetto e
questo si sa aprite che sole mezzogiorno
fame aia presa porta sono i ragni grossi
da una [ __ ] mi fa schifo
mamma mia che schifo orribile io ci ho
questo problema ce l'avevo anche quando
giocavo a world of warcraft o problema
quando c'erano i ragni madonna non
riuscivo a giocarci perché ogni volta
che c'è un ragno loschi vago anche se no
magari molto più forte di lui perché mi
faceva schifo sì basta ho capito sono
morto basta fammi uscire esco exit a
buongiorno questa si chiama kris kris
kris kris dopo l'operazione ovviamente
d'accordo ragazzi è stato cioè non ho
capito come breve niente però è stato
figo dato il momento figlio durante il
video c'è stato
però vale quindi la gazzoli spero che
questo video vi sia piaciuto cosa che mi
piace un momento non mi piace anche vari
social che come insieme di sensori di
scrittrici vediamo un posto video belle
ragazze